hello everyone and welcome to the last
game I'll be covering from the 1959
candidates tournament it's Bobby Fischer
with the white pieces against Michael
tile this is their fourth game they were
playing in this tournament this is
around 27 and this is in my opinion the
best game the two of them have played in
this tournament it's it's really crazy
and it's very interesting how tall so
far into the tournament it's it's round
27 I he plays as such a risky opening
and he really accepts all of Fischer's
challenges and you know in the end it
produces such an amazing game so before
we see this game I don't think I mean
it's probably not the last game I'll
cover from the 19 candidates tournament
but for now and you know later if I
missed some of your favorite games you
can also suggest them and I will add
them to this playlist but before we get
started of course we should marvel at
our photo here we have a towel playing
against Fischer it's not from this
tournament but it's also from 1959 so
just so we get a better feel of the game
even though the color of the piece is
reversed but nevertheless so let's see
it Bobby has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 and we have the standard
set up between fish running towel
c5 distill in defense night of 3 D 6 and
D for C captures Knight captures Knight
to f6 and Knight to c3 a6 we have the
knight of variation and Fischer goes for
his favorite Bishop to c4 e6 and the
Bishop to b3 and Thal goes for the
immediate b5 now here you could go for
some safer choices like a three but
Fischer goes for the immediate f4 and
this is this is a bit too risky but tal
accepts the challenge he plays before he
kicks the defender of the e4 pawn we
have 9th to a4 and now Knight captures
on e4 so tall grabs a pawn and Fischer
castles so what do you do here
Tom plays g6 and here Fischer plays the
sharpest of moves he plays f5 so now you
don't really want to allow F captures on
e6 or F captures on g6 to allow this
rook on f1
to become active the problem would a
move like he captures on f5 is now white
can play Bishop to d5 attacking the rook
on a8 and after you move the rook now
comes and Knight captures on f5 but
Bishop captures now comes Queen to d4
and now the knight on e4 is attacked
twice the rook is attacked an i7 the
rook is attacked on h8 and after black
defense this would Knight to f6 getting
the knight out of harm's way and also
blocking the attack to the rook on h8
now we don't capture the rookin a7 but
first we play Bishop to g5 now you
attack the knight first Bishop to e7
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
rook to e1 and only after the king moves
king f8 and now you capture and now you
have a much better position as white
so after this f5 move now played G
captures on f5 but this still elites the
very complicated position here Fischer
played Knight captures on f5 and pal
doesn't grab the night because then you
get a bit up to d5 immediately so rook
the g8 not allowing that idea of Queen
to d4 attacking both rooks Fischer
continues with Bishop to b5 now
attacking the rook on a8 and it's
interesting what happens if you capture
the bishop ECE capture some d5 then
simply Queen captures on d5 again your
knight is attacked your rook is attacked
on a8 and after Bishop captures on f5
now you don't grab the rook but you play
Queen captures on f5 threatening the
knight on e4 and also threatening Queen
captures on f7 checkmate
so after we block this knife to f6 now
comes Bishop to g5 again Bishop to g7
Bishop captures Bishop captures and
Queen to e4 check checking the King and
again picking up the rock and a8 white
is winning here so after this Bishop to
d5 move top plays rook to a7 and here we
have Bishop captures on e4 e Capra's on
f5 we have Bishop captures on e5 an f5
and now rook to e7
bunch of characters on c8 Queen captures
on c8 and Bishop to f4
attacking this d6 form tower plays Queen
to see
six attacking the night and a four and
here Fisher does have a lot of options
but he chooses again a very daring one
he plays Queen to f3 and now Tao Tao
can't really afford to trade Queens he
he's not gonna gain much out of this
after Queen captures after we recapture
the material is equal but talus bone
structure is much worse
he has like four point islands fira has
only 2 so this would this would favor
white greatly
so after this Queen to f3 move Tao
actually decides to accept the challenge
she captures the knight and a4 so Queen
captures night and now we have Bishop
captures and b6 and again you can't
really move the rook anywhere along the
e-file because Queen captures on f7 is
coming and if you try to save your work
by playing something like rook to d7
then you get rook 881 check King to d8
and now Queen to f6 check King to see it
now you get rook check King moves rook
captures King moves Bishop captures
creating a check from the Queen and f6
King e5 raqqa 5 check King c4 and now
rook the c5 checkmate
I just this is just one of the
variations but all of the variations
leads to a win for white so after this
Bishop to d6 move Tao plays Queen back
to c6
we have Bishop captures on b8 and now
comes Queen to b6 check checking the
king and of course picking up the bishop
on be a king - h1 and here we have Queen
captures on b8 and here this is the
critical moment of the game I actually
actually wrote this above above the
board as a quote but I seem to have
forgotten to update my interface this
was actually the moment the title
suggests here
Fischer has to play rook 81 and with
playing this move he can continue this
game and it will most likely be a draw
if neither player makes any mistakes but
Fischer actually wrote down this move
rook 81 on his paper because in those
days you could write down a move and
then consider it think about it for a
bit maybe even change it you didn't have
to play it unlike today today
have to firstly move and then write it
down which is III think that's that's
not very cool when I started playing
chess you know I could write the move
down then I and and that's how people
who were like experienced players they
taught me first to try to move down then
you like you know really ponder on the
move and imagine it being played but now
this first you have to play a move and
only then write it down like it's some
sort of you know follow up I don't
really enjoy this but maybe even that
rule change so I don't know so after
official wrote this move down at also
what Fisher wrote down and Dahl just
gave him a little grin he smiled at him
and then Fisher really started to
consider what he wrote down this route
81 and then Fisher actually decided this
wasn't a good move as he said he didn't
really see why it wasn't a good move but
because tal smiled at him Fisher thought
that thought was actually telling him
that it's a mistake so instead of this
rook 81 Fisher played Queen to c6 and
Queen to c6 check actually gives Stahl
the only defense possible on the board
because if route 81 and now of course
you can't capture because of Queen
captures on f7 and even if you don't
capture Queen captures on f7 is a is a
threat because the rook on e7 is pinned
so after King to d8 unpinning and now
you capture it and after Bishop captures
Queen to d5 trick and now you can't
block with the Queen if Queen to d6 then
Queen to 8 check you pick up the rockin
g8 so after Bishop to d6 blocking now
simply rook to f6 attacking the bishop
and after rook the g6 rook captures on
f7 and even with being a piece of black
can't make any progress here because the
king is Barenaked here on d8 the white
can simply continue checking him
so after this Queen to b8 move Fischer
unfortunately for Fischer didn't play
this rook 81 and here you can see here
you can see the power of psychology in
chess
Fischer actually found the best move he
wrote it down he's ready to play it but
because tal smiled at him Fischer
actually thought that this wasn't a good
move and
all had something hidden in store for
him so first play queen to c6 check but
now comes rope to d7 and now you can see
there's a really no way for white to
continue this attack of course the move
rook a to e1 is coming but simply Bishop
to e7 and there really isn't a better
move Fischer played rook 81 tal blocked
Bishop to e7 and here you really don't
have a way of continuing this attack
whatsoever
you could try there's really nothing you
could try here Fischer tried one more
thing he tried rope captures on f7
what's the idea that if King captures he
will capture the d7 rook and then Palace
king will kind of be stuck in the center
so maybe he can still draw this game but
unfortunately for him it doesn't work
doc captured the rook and now Fischer
doesn't capture captures rook
immediately firstly plays a queen to e6
check of course not with King to e8 and
Queen captures on g8 is checkmate the
bishop is pinned
but tal doesn't fall for this he plays
King to f8 and only now Queen captures
on b7 now tau play Queen to d6 and now
you can see that black defended
successfully and now tau will certainly
enjoy being up a piece but Fischer is
far from resigning if he can snatch for
example one more pawn
then he could actually maybe have some
drawing chances as the king is still
wide open
so Queen - b7 by Fischer now comes Rock
to g6 c 3 a 5 I would have Queen to c8
check King to g7 and now Queen to c4
Bishop to d8 and now comes pawn captures
pawn captures and we have g3 and with
this g3 move you can see the Fischer
doesn't really have a way of making any
progress here so Bishop to c7 is
definitely coming pressuring Fischer's
position so Fischer played g3 but this
allows start to exchange Queen so Queen
to c6 immediately and now we have rook
to e4 Queen captures rook captures and
Tull was confident that although Fisher
is fisheries up two points for the 40
extra piece
but Dahl was confident that he could win
this endgame so rook to b6 defending the
b4 pawn as tough couldn't really I mean
in positions like this you can't really
afford to give up a plan upon even
though your your upper piece so King to
g2 both layers now bring their king into
the game
Bishop the bg5 check King 2b - and now
King to d5 attacking the rook King
defense Bishop to f6 rook to c2 and now
Bishop to e5 rook to e2 rook to f6 now
rook to c2 rook to f3 check King to e2
and now rook back to f7 King back to d3
and now Bishop to d4 and here you can
see that now
Tallis completely controlling Fischer
skiing here on d3 moves like rook to f3
check rook to have to check are coming
so Fisher tries a three but now simply B
3 and here it doesn't help you if you if
you move the rook anywhere along the
second rank to kind of protect the B to
pawn I even if you play something like
rook to eat - you still get rook left
recheck and after the King moves you
simply grab the pawn here so that
doesn't work
Fischer tried rook the c8 now comes
Bishop captures so tower grabs a pawn
rook checks and d8 King moves rook to b8
attacking the pawn and B 3 but now rook
to f3 check King to c4 and now rook the
c3 check King to before and now King to
c7 attacking the rook rook the B 5 and
we have Bishop to a1 Fischer pushes a 4
but here tells him to place B 2 and it
was in this position and this is move 52
that Bobby Fischer resigned the game
what if you resign well it's pretty
obvious you can't really stop the bee to
pawn if you capture the rook then
unfortunately
pawn coming to be 1 and promoting to a
queen
this comes with a discovered check from
the bishop so you can't win the Queen
and if you try something like came to a5
then simply rook the c1 and there is no
defense against b1 IROC will have the
capture and then a bishop and the rook
are quite sufficient to win this game so
after 50 second move the
be too tall pushed official resign the
game and yeah and and he won the 1959
candidates tournament so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it this is a one
of the one of the more beautiful games
the two of them played in this
tournament if not the most beautiful one
I don't know you know there are a lot of
different opinions and like I said this
will be my last game from the 1959
candidates tournament not probably and
forever but unless some of you suggest
any games any cool games I missed I will
now move on to some other tournaments
and maybe check up on some current
events if any of you have any
suggestions on any current events like
for example I saw a very nice game in
the Aeroflot open between I believe it
was se Penco versus Johan Salomon that
was a pretty theatrical ending so I
might cover that one and maybe I'll give
it a day or two and then I will start
the 1960 World Chess Championship
between Michael Tao and Mikhail
Botvinnik so for the last time we should
marvel at the final standings at this
tournament as you can see Michael Tao
won the tournament with 20 out of 28
points then comes Paul Karason second
place
Tigran Petrosian in third the vasily
smyslov so it was allegory to robert
james fisher or bobby free recall of son
and pal Benko in the last place with
eight out of 28 and of course since Tull
won the tournament tall won the right to
challenge Mikhail Botvinnik for the
World Chess Championship title so that's
probably the series I'm planning to
cover next I'm going to cover all of the
games even though a lot of games were
drawn but I think you know I should
cover that entire match so yeah and yeah
I wanted to mention that this was
actually the last game Bobby Fischer
ever lost the towel so all the other
games Fischer ever played against Al
were either drawn or won by Fischer
I mean all the games didn't play that
much games Fischer won two of the games
and from classical chess and he want to
rapid games and the five games were
drawn
but yeah I have a book by Demetri bill
it's my friend Bobby Fischer and he says
that Demetrius says that he was walking
alongside Bobby when he was preparing to
play against Michael Todd after this
tournament I don't know I don't know
what year that was but he said that
after he lost those four games to tau
that he will cut his ear off if he loses
another game from tau but he didn't so
he has both of his ears fortunately so
yeah I think that's that's about it for
the 1959 candidates I do hope you
enjoyed it this game and the coverage of
the entire tournament now with our vast
knowledge we can truly appreciate the
1960 World Chess Championship match so I
would like to thank James of under neck
a lot of it because the era of Davis
mumma John McDonald and Francis Armand
la Fontaine and more for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with some interesting content
I hope thank you